احتكاك روسي امريكي خطير مقاتله روسيه
مقابل مسيره امريكيه في تفاصيل الحادثه
التي وصفت بالخطيره
اصطدمت مقاتله روسيه من طراز سوخويت وانت
7 بطائره امريكيه مسيره من طراز ام كيو 9
ريبر وقالت واشنطن ان قواتها اضطرت الى
اسقاط مسيره في البحر الاسود اما موسكو
فتقول ان الحادثه وقعت بالقرب من جزيره
القرم لكن لماذا وجدت مسيره امريكيه
بطريقه استفزت روسيا فوق البحر الاسود
المسؤولون العسكريون الامريكيون يقولون ان
الطائره المسيره كانت تقوم بعمليات
روتينيه في المجال الجوي الدولي اما
البنتاجون فاستنكر الحادثه واتهم
المقاتلات الروسيه بالقاء الوقود امام
المسيرات الامريكيه الا انه رفض الافصاح
عما اذا كانت مسيره مسلحه ام لا
المهمه التي كانت تقوم بها بينما للروس
روايه اخرى فهم ينظرون للحادث باعتباره
استفزازا موسكو نفتعمدها اسقاط المسيره
الامريكيه وقالت ان ام كيو 9 ريبر تحطمت
بعد ارتطامها بسطح البحر الاسود لاسباب
تعود لفقدانها الارتفاع بعد قيامها
بمناوره حاده واثناء تحليقها اطفات اجهزه
تعريفها في انتهاك لمنطقه الحظر الجوي ما
دفع مقاتلتين روسيتين الاعتراضها الا
انهما لم تسقطاها ولم تقترب منها بشكل
خطير مستبعدين رغبه موسكو بالمواجهه مع
واشنطن حتى الان للولايات المتحده ولا
روسيا تمكنتا من استعاده حطام المسيره
الامريكيه الا ان هذا التصعيد الاخير حذر
منه مسؤول البلدين خاصه وانه اول مواجهه
مباشره بين الطرفين منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا روان حمزه العربيه